World War Z spent 25 million dollars
like a Brad Pitt fighting a zombie army
in Russia now that the latest scene
ain't coming back to life these films
left buku bugs at The Cutting Room floor
with its crazy time travel plots X-Men
Days of Future pastors packed with
familiar faces but unfortunately that
means limited screen time for some of
our favorite characters including Anna
paquin's Rogue a True Blood actress
spent a week filming several elaborate
scenes for the 2014 Blockbuster
alongside original trilogy vets Ian
McAllen Patrick Stewart and Sean Ashmore
but none of it wound up in the finished
film director Brian Singer told
Entertainment Weekly through the editing
process the sequence became extraneous
like many things in the editing process
it was an embarrassment of riches and it
was just one of the things I had to go
Paquin didn't sound too disappointed in
an interview with Yahoo saying I got to
hang out with my friends for five days
in Montreal see people have known for
two decades and go play did it end up in
the movie no well it was fun anyway but
after fun outcry 20th Century Fox
release a road cut of the film on DVD
restoring 17 minutes of previous seat
cut footage that included pack Quinn's
sequences
if all the gun is director Frank ozin's
creedmizer Howard Ashman had initially
planned the 1986 adaptation of the
Broadway musical Little Shop of Horrors
wouldn't have ended quite as happily in
the theatrical ending Seymour and Audrey
live out there happily ever after
following a climax in which Seymour
electrocutes Audrey too oh
foreign
[Music]
however the filmmakers intended to use
the ending from the stage version of
Little Shop of Horrors with Audrey 2
eating Audrey and Seymour and
terrorizing the world but test audiences
hated it I'll record to Entertainment
Weekly for every music or number there
was Applause they loved it it was just
fantastic until we killed our two leads
and then the theater became a
refrigerator an icebox the elaborate 23
minute sequence which costs a reported
five million dollars was scraps and a
new ending was shot with the two leads
alive and well though a black and white
version of the original ending was
included on a 1998 DVD release full
color footage was finally included in a
director's cut edition Blu-ray in 2012.
if you've watched World War Z and
thought the ending seemed out of place
that's a good reason why after the
battle in Jerusalem the movie ended on a
jarring small-scale switch with Brad
Pitt's Jerry wandering around the
research laboratory to find a cure and
ultimately reuniting with his family but
the ending we got was the backup option
for the original script which finished
things off in a far more epic fashion in
the original ending Jerry and his
sidekick second made it to Russia and
joined the anti-zombie army the story
then skipped ahead to the winter showing
Jerry leading the Russian army into
massive zombie battles he contacted his
wife Karen it left him and wasn't in
relationship with one of the soldiers we
saw at the beginning of the film
supposedly the soldier played by Matthew
Fox not about to lose his family Joey
embarked on a quest across Siberia
trying to reach the Pacific Ocean and
find a way to his wife's camp in America
it's a downer ending that would have set
up a whole trilogy of World War Z films
but this wasn't just a script idea most
of the third Act was actually filmed but
at the last minute Paramount decided to
go with a lighter more full ending the
reshoots ended up costing 25 million
dollars that's a huge amount of money
especially since none of the original
third Act was used in the Final Cut
frankly the original version sounds
awesome we never knew we needed a
bearded Brad Pitt leading the Russians
into epic zombie battles until now
dreamy dimwitted secretary Kevin is a
much help around the Ghostbusters office
he's more concerned with picking out his
best audition headshots and flirting
with the ladies and answering the phone
in an aquarium is a submarine for fish
but when he's possessed by Rowan during
the film's climax he uses his new powers
to make hordes of army personnel and
police officers do whatever he wants if
you think it feels like the perfect
segue into a dance number you'd be right
director Paul feig spent two days and
somewhere in the vicinity of seven
figures shooting an entire dance number
with Hemsworth and Extras to the BG's
you should be dancing but it was
ultimately cut fig told vulture it was
stopping the flow for the audience
because even though they really loved it
they were having trouble coming back out
of it it was making the Rhythm a little
too goofy in a weird way rather than
completely scrap the footage fig
re-edited it and used it during the
film's credits some audiences would
still get to see Hemsworth busting a
move the sequence was also restored for
the Extended Cut on Blu-ray before DC
decided to reboot the Superman franchise
in 2013 was Zack's nighter at the helm
Brian singers 2006 entries starring
Brandon Routh as a cape superhero flew
into movie theaters with fairly mixed
reviews Superman Returns also nearly
arrived with a completely different
opening sequence while the basic plot of
the film deals to Superman's return to
worth after a five-year absence singer
shot a worthless visually stunning
five-minute opening sequence with Rouse
Kalel returning to Krypton the scene
which costs an estimated 10 million
dollars feels like something closer to
Stanley Kubrick's 2001 A Space Odyssey
then a slick superhero film it's slow
and contemplative rather than bombastic
and perhaps this is why producers
ultimately had singer cutter the scene
was finally released as an extra on the
2011 Superman Anthology Blu-ray set
further dividing critics and fans on the
one-off superhero flick
at the end of Dr Strangelove or how I
learned to stop worrying and love the
bomb the U.S dispatches a group of B-52s
to drop h-bombs on the Soviet Union but
winds up abandoning the planet the last
minute unfortunately One play manages to
drop its bombs which triggers a nuclear
chain reaction to The Elegant strains
that we'll meet again however director
stunned the Kubrick envisioned a much
different a Messier ending to his 1964
satirical Masterpiece in an effort to
show the complete absurdity of War
Kubrick filmed a giant pie fight between
his principal Cass and the War Room in
just one take due to the mass and
expensive shooting the scene kicks off
with a pie hitting the president in the
face which according to BFI leads to the
line our beloved president has been
infamously struck down by a pie in the
prime of his life however the film's
test screening happened on the day of
John F Kennedy's assassination and
suddenly the whole sequence felt
problematic Kubrick in the studio agreed
that the pie fight didn't match the rest
of the film's tone and cut the scene for
creative and political reasons
visual footage still exists still photos
of the sceno included in the DVD extras
the 1940s set my movie Gangster Squad
starring Sean Penn Ryan Gosling Josh
Brolin and Emma Stone once featured a
key scene set of grand men's in Los
Angeles the sequence saw a pack of
gangsters opened fire on the audience
causing the theater to erupt in Mayhem
the film was set to be released in early
September of 2012 but tragedy struck
that July in Aurora Colorado a gunman
opened fire on a theater full of
moviegoers at a midnight screening of
The Dark Knight Rises Warner Brothers
the studio behind both The Dark Knight
Rises and Gangster Squad immediately
pulled the lattice trailer from theaters
and pushed back its release date in
order to allow for extensive rewrites
and reshoots released in early 2013
Gangster Squad featured an all-new
ending and director Ruben Fleischer had
no problem with her telling Indie wire
during a press conference we felt it
necessary to reshoot that sequence and
I'm proud of the fact that we did I
think that we didn't compromise the film
or our intent and I think the newly shot
Chinatown sequence has really well done
and that we should all respect the
tragedy and not draw associations to our
film
that's most Back to the Future fans know
Eric stolz was originally cast as Marty
McFly the puffy vest wearing teenager
sent back to 1955 in a souped-up
DeLorean director Robert zamakis
initially wanted to hire Michael J fox
but his family ties shooting schedule
was too demanding at the time and hired
Stoltz instead five weeks into filming
zamekus and Steven Spielberg knew they
needed to replace stars in an excerpt
from a book on the making of the film
called we don't need roads the making of
the Back to the Future Trilogy co-star
Leah Thompson remarked Eric had such an
intensity he saw drama in things he
wasn't really a comedian and they needed
a comedian he's super funny in real life
but he didn't approach his work like
that and they really needed somebody who
had those chops tamekius and Spielberg
quickly negotiates here with universal
to replace stalls with Fox adding a
reported 3 million dollars to the film's
budget and extra time onto its shooting
schedule soon Fox was on set at the Twin
Pines more shooting with Christopher
Lloyd and the rest is history
reporters are interviewing the gang at
the end of The Goonies they to say
something kind of surprising for them
and the audience
it turns out the gangs really did have a
close encounter of the ace armed kind in
the original version of the 1985 called
classic The Goonies Korean down watery
shoots and London a lagoon only to be
attacked by a rubbery giant octopus
foreign
into its mouth or blasting a pop track
written for the film entitled eight arms
to hold you and the octopus swims away a
lot of work went into the scene which
was fully edited and scored for
inclusion in the film most likely the
fabled scene was cut for time or deemed
unnecessary and cheesy looking when the
Disney Channel acquired the TV rights to
the film in the 90s the network added
the scene back in to make up for lost
air time after deleting scenes deemed
inappropriate for young children while
the scene is only included in the DVD
extras data's non-secreta Revelation
Still Remains in the Final Cut of the
film
a curious group of movies were released
in and around the 2000s that defies
simple classification but all seems
surprisingly similar for lack of a
succinct nickname we'll call them modern
fantasy horror adventures in Blended
medieval Victorian steampunk settings
that sounds convoluted but it's
explained best by its constituent movies
such as Red Riding Hood but Helsing and
Hansel and Gretel witch Hunters all of
them devoted considerable time and money
to combining digital and practical
effects which made them all extra
expensive one film on this odd subgenre
2005's of Brothers Grimm wasted a lot of
that expense on a single battle which
was cut from the movie entirely the
scene which survives with a DVD extra
shows Brothers will and Jake Grimm
trying to save Angelica from a massive
tree that's magically come to life it's
apparent that many of the roots and
branches were built as models while the
writhing branches were all digital and
the combination Alba guarantees has seen
a hefty price tag director Terry Gilliam
confirmed as much to the guardian saying
I cut out the most expensive scene in
the movie it'll be my DVD the most
expensive extra ever made it's a great
sequence a fight in a tree
if you've seen The Amazing Spider-Man
and at sequel you know they revolve
around Peter Parker and Gwen Stacy
played by Andrew Garfield and Emma Stone
the two films are notable for their
decision to focus on the relationship
between Parker and Stacey replacing the
Parker and Mary Jane relationship that
was Central in some Remy Spiderman
Trilogy what you may not know is that MJ
was originally in The Amazing Spider-Man
2 appeared in multiple scenes and was
even played by well-known actress
Shailene Woodley unfortunately for both
Woodley and Mary Jane fans her entire
presence was cut from the film before
release producer Matt told Mark
explained a decision to cut will lead to
the Los Angeles Times saying it felt
like a distraction you can't have Peter
thinking about Gwen every moment and
then there's this girl next door who's
suddenly there we weren't ready for it
more the cost of cutting out from this
film is unclear what leaves pay for
other projects in the 2010s tended to
hover for around the 200 to 250 000 Mark
per movie making it likely her deleted
scenes cost quite a bit and when you
factor in Garfield's time given his five
hundred thousand dollar payday for the
first movie it's likely that a lot of
money was left on The Cutting Room floor
if you haven't seen the Raider at sequel
The Raid 2 you're not alone despite both
pictures receiving excellent reviews
from critics and fans alike neither
became a commercial hit in the United
States thus reductions of the Indonesian
film industry the two movies have had a
steadily increasing following on
streaming services and DVD but both
remain relatively hidden cinematic gems
nonetheless the movies retain their
small but dedicated following thanks in
large parts of that consistently
over-the-top action and violence both of
which are on display in a large-scale
deleted scene known as gang war the
scene is available online though a
warning for those who haven't seen the
films is exceptionally violent gang war
was personally posted by the film's
director Gareth Evans as part of the
marketing for The Raid 2 and under the
post Evans gave his own colorful
approximation of the sequence's cast he
wrote this was probably the hardest for
me to cut due to the fact that the
production on this scene lasted around
six days of shooting and it cost us a
follow to make as hard as it is to pin
an exact amount to gang war Evan's
subscription gives us a pretty good idea
that it's certainly wasn't cheap
movies cast an arm and a leg to make
that's why production companies
sometimes go looking for funds in the
weirdest of places which is where
product placement comes in sometimes
producers are desperate enough for that
sweet sweet product placement money that
their film ends up becoming essentially
one giant ad happily Die Hard 2 avoided
that fate tragically only did so because
it ended up deleting its product
placement prompting a very costly
lawsuit in exchange for twenty thousand
dollars from Black and Decker Die Hard 2
producers agreed to feature a scene in
which hero John McLean used one of the
company's signature univolt power drills
randomly expecting the scene to make it
to theaters Black and Decker began
marketing the drill with Die Hard tie-in
ads not a cheap Affair when the scene
was cut from the movie Black and Decker
suit distributor 20th Century Fox 150
000 hoping to recoup its advertising
costs the thing is black and Decker's
case was strong enough that 20th Century
Fox agreed to settle out of court likely
causing them to rule the day they ever
dared to cut a convenient durable
product of the univault
when Disney began developing Star Wars
the Force awakens they knew that they
had to get it right which is why they
threw tons of cachate according to
filings obtained by Forbes the force
awakens was made with the largest budget
of all time as over 533 million dollars
with a budget like that every single
minute of deleted film was by extension
ridiculously expensive you might not
know about its deleted scenes as a Star
Wars franchise doesn't tend to publicize
its cut content in the way that other
franchises do first they are plentiful
big budget actors like Harrison Ford and
Adam Driver have minutes of their work
cut entire practical effects sets
complete with costumes and props
occurred and even scenes with finished
digital effects occurs like those
featuring CG alien Mars Kanata
there are a few movies as Titanic as
Avengers end game upon release has
snapped several box office records to
dust bias grossing opening weekend
fastest film to reach 1 billion dollars
numerous single day records and even for
a while highest grossing film of all
time still as the old saying goes it
takes money to make money and Avengers
end game is no exception costing an
estimated 400 million dollars a big
chunk of that paid for its
unprecedentedly star-studded cast is
that everyone
[Music]
and unfortunately for fans and many of
that cast group scenes ended up on The
Cutting Room floor as the film
screenwriters told the New York Times
the climactic battle sequence was
originally a whole lot longer with quote
its own three-act structure one of the
cut moments was a scene with a whopping
18 characters on set together in a
trench in fact well over 10 minutes of
film's footage was cut much of which
featured the franchise's signature cast
members with the knowledge that Robert
Downey Jr earned 20 million dollars up
front for his role Chris Evans Chris
Hemsworth and Scarlett Johansson made 15
million dollars each and dozens of other
big stars were getting Millions for
their time we can safely conclude that
every minute of the Avengers end game
deleted scenes came with a hefty price
tag the wicked witch uses a lot of
different tactics to try to stop Dorothy
and her friends in The Wizard of Oz but
one never made it into the final version
of the film in the last Jitterbug
sequence Dorothy the Scarecrow Tin Man
and Cowardly Lion travel through the
Haunted Woods only to be attacked by
evil bugs that cause them to break out
in song and dance
also a popular dance Stars at the time
the jitterberg was actually a remnant of
an older version of the script that was
tossed out the whole number cost about
eighty thousand dollars and took five
weeks to shoot but it was excised when
producers deemed the film too long
although the actual footage was
apparently destroyed composer Howard
Allen captured a dress rehearsal of the
number on home video later included as
an extra on the DVD version of the film
foreign